what's up everyone this is the first
time I've actually been live before so
you know not getting married
nope nope nope I've got some pretty big
announcements about some kind of changes
coming to the channel what's up YouTube
cracked
what's up original otaku hello oh yeah
what's up guys what is up
I am Liam Adam Jack what's up everybody
I know most of you probably haven't seen
my face before I have done a few videos
where I put myself in videos but I not
not often do I do it I like to keep it
thanks James appreciate that James
Archer thanks Joseph
I like to keep it about the content so I
don't put a lot of my self in my
channels thanks Jackson Powell I do play
videogames Adriana I'm going to hey
Fenwick what up dude I'm going to start
playing video games on a separate
channel not going to kind of saturate my
channel playing video games but thanks
for all joining me tonight I have a few
announcements
I want to make thanks Tyler appreciate
that
yeaji feel big Nate yep I am sponsored
by G field now use code cosmic if you
want to discount on it when you check
out so if you're subscribed to my
channel for mortal content that makes
sense because all I talk about is Marvel
content there is a lot of stuff coming
like a lot a lot of stuff coming no it's
not a fan of Shaker it's a pixel potion
shaker just kind of like to twitch
inspired one so yes whoever just asked
that I am getting the Avengers game when
it comes out eventually
thanks biggie cope but today I want to
talk about new content coming to my
channel so a lot of Marvel content
coming like a lot of Marvel content
coming so
of course with face for coming out we
have leaks that are just there just out
there every day I try to sort through
the ones that dick to the source to see
which ones kind of had the most credits
there's websites out there they don't
really offer a lot of legitimate leaks I
try to avoid those so a lot of leaks up
there even photos I did a black widow
video today with some leaked official
promo art that came out so as long
elique scum in for face for phase five
just the rest of it all
so also what's come in is just a ton of
Disney plushies so I'm gonna be covering
all the Disney plushies that are here
just just a ton of them and I mean Loki
just want a vision they're all going to
connect to the movie so it's going to be
crazy
Inhumans yes they're whoever asked that
there is a possibility that they could
come back
so the Disney Plus shows phase four
phase five and then I'm also going to be
doing theories as well as you all know I
do theories I think the majority of the
people i YouTubed Lord brawler I saw it
yeah tonne of theories did a Galactus
one before everybody seemed to like it
there's a lot more Galactus ones there's
a lot more kind of everything ones that
I have coming out and then today I don't
know if you saw Arthur Fleck
oh the Arthur flick I saw you with and
Theory Thursdays are coming back yes I
saw that
they're gonna come back I'll talk about
that later but basically what's gonna
happen is a lot more Marvel content
coming to channel because I'm going to
start doing top 10 videos I did a top I
think I did like five greatest or five
weapons that are stronger than the
Infinity Gauntlet today so more like
that because a lot of people have been
asking me to talk more about the comics
because they don't really they don't
really know about the comics and not a
lot of people have access to them not a
lot of people have read them so I'll
definitely hi Tyler so I'll definitely
be going and doing more content about
the comics because that's that's what I
truly enjoy that's kind of how I started
I get a lot of comment my Tyrion and
when I started so me doing that and then
I'll be going over just big events from
the comics like Avengers vs. x-men I'll
be doing this as well so another thing
is I know a lot of people love my
Marvel stuff and it's gonna stay there
nothing's changing except for the fact
that I'm going to do even more Marvel
stuff but like I'm going to be
introducing DC content and Star Wars
content to my channel as well not a ton
of it Marvel is always gonna take
presidents for what I'm doing
anytime news comes out about that stuff
I'm just gonna do that thanks Warren
right so nothing's ever gonna take
presidents ever Marvel like ever so if
something comes out it's always gonna be
Marvel Marvel is always gonna be first
but having said that there are a lot of
DC stuff coming out that's actually
really exciting Suicide Squad by James
Gunn that's gonna be crazy James Gunn
did an amazing job
amazing job birds of prey the Joker was
amazing like it was crazy good for that
type of high crazy gamer I didn't really
see what you said but you said you never
noticed me so I just noticed you tons of
DC content coming up and the stuff is
just so good really like there it's
gonna get better
I write Joker was epic I see a lot of
people saying that so for those of you
who are just kind of worried that Marvel
content is gonna stop it's not gonna
stop at all no not it's gonna get more
alright we're gonna do more there's
gonna be more content on my channel I'm
gonna introduce a show aspect to my
channel as well when I bring people on
some other youtubers some friends some
other just crazy comic nerds that are
just like all of us that just love to
see all this stuff so that's gonna be
cool and then DC Kevin Feige is gonna be
kind of in charge of DC so that's gonna
be crazy exciting or I'm sorry not DC
Star Wars Kevin Feige is gonna kind of
go over and helping with the Star Wars
now so that should be cool so if the
content is good and it's gonna be there
then I'm gonna hi Chris if the content
is good and it's there I'm gonna talk
about it I'm just gonna remain mostly a
Marvel channel really that's my passion
that's I do play spider-man ps4 but I
haven't seen it in a very long time if
there was a Marvel crossover only on my
channel not in real life
that would be pretty crazy I have played
marble strike
worse that actually leads me to another
announcement I will be starting a twitch
channel soon and I'm just gonna be you
know doing all that stuff I'm gonna be
playing all the Marvel games Ultimate
Alliance 3 putting all that in there any
Marvel game in any game just kind of
that I enjoy doing anywhere yes of what
up shout out to USM so having said that
a lot of good stuff coming but I want
your input on on what's what's happening
hi AMS hallo Danny yes Danny what up
dude I do play Super Smash I'll be doing
that too
so I want your input on all this stuff
that's coming so Marvel there's just so
much coming let me know what you would
like to see because like I said I'm
going to be doing top 5 top tens I'm
going to be doing more comic stuff like
The Avengers vs. x-men crossovers and
stuff like done in the comics I'm going
to be you know covering those and
talking about what they mean in the
comics a lot of people have said that
they want more of that and that's the
stuff I truly enjoy doing so I'm gonna
do it
theories of course gonna always continue
to do theories Oh always yeah and Disney
Plus was gonna come out too so just a
lot of cool stuff a lot of new material
so let me know what you want to see
what's up Jillian love you too so let me
know what you want from Marvel content
let me know what you think of the DC
content so let me know about that let me
know what you think about the Star Wars
content with Kevin Feige coming really
I'm most excited for the mandalorian
like that's crazy crazy cool I really
enjoy I what I've seen so far so I think
it's gonna be really good so I'm gonna
cover that I think it'll be fun I'm
gonna cover some DC stuff I think it's
gonna be fun
so let's let's hear what you have to say
I'm doing good thanks Daxton I wanna
hear what you have to say about this
content coming out let me know what you
think let me know what you would like to
hear what you would like to see because
a lot of exciting stuff scum in a lot of
content coming that I think that things
that you're all going to enjoy so again
leave and leave a comment down below
what you think is like the best thing
thanks 10/10
Mario fan you're awesome too yes I am
gonna do
Avengers damage control there is a void
right next to my house however it's not
really out yet
it kind of just opened and it's not even
listed on one of the places you can play
it so I'm not sure if they have Avengers
damage control there but I am gonna get
my manager to call them and they're
gonna see you know if I can go in and I
can play because I am going out of town
going to Europe for three weeks so I the
day before it actually comes out so if I
could play it early by any chance I'm
going to I'm gonna try so if I have
anything like I could show you from
Avengers damage control with the virtual
reality of interest game I'll show you
unfortunately it's only in like I think
10 places in in in the the US I think
maybe like two places outside of the US
I think one was in like Malaysia and
maybe one of the Netherlands or
somewhere maybe Canada something like
that so unfortunately there's just not a
lot of places to play that so oh I
wanted to dress 3 Thursday so the reason
I stopped doing Theory Thursday is
because I kept getting copyright claims
so obviously thousands of people would
send me theories and obviously some of
them were kind of the same as other
theories so well unfortunately I would
post a theory set by one person and I
would get an email saying hey this was
my theory and it was just kind of like
sorry it was this other person's theory
like you know it was thanks Kyle so
people would get mad that I posted a
person's theory because they thought it
was their theory but I got thousands of
theories and they all kind of blended
together you know just because of how
many I got so unfortunately people would
copyright them and then I would have to
you know fight the dispute claiming that
you know it's it's not copyright so I
had to do that so that's kind of why I
stopped doing Theory Thursdays for a
while but know a lot of people like it
so I'm just trying to figure out a way
to get around that just so I don't make
people mad thinking what's up venoth
Kempe
Thanks I just want to try not to make
people you know too mad because I'm not
trying to rip anybody's theories off
just obviously with the amount of
theories that I get some theories are
gonna be the same as other people's
theories so no sorry but uh this is it
for the chat guys thought I'd go live
just to talk about some new stuff coming
so more Marvel content than ever I'm
gonna be super busy with everything
that's coming out plus gonna do new
theories the top five the top ten is
going over events from the comics gonna
do some DC videos gonna do some Star
Wars videos and because that stuff's
just kind of what I really really enjoy
and there's a lot of new stuff with
Disney Plus coming out so let me know
Tyler Evans shout out let me know what
you think is the best content out there
right now as far as Marvel DC and Star
Wars let me know what abarth of like
just let me know thanks leak and let me
know what you think is gonna be the most
exciting stuff coming out let me know
what you're most excited for and let me
know what content you like top five top
tens comic book stories vs. series I do
that on my channel multiverse I have my
personal channel culture captains where
I just do stupid things like Pogo stuck
you can find all these channels and the
sidebar on my YouTube page where it's
like the channels top fives I see that
yeah it is gonna all be on this channel
I haven't chose anyone to win the
nfinity saga thing yet because it's not
out yet
so I'm not gonna do that giveaway until
it's out just doesn't make sense but
when I hit five hundred fifty thousand
subscribers I will be giving away an
Xbox one or a ps4 that'll probably be
the last time I do that give away
because the PS 5 is coming out sometimes
I don't know when the Psy was gonna come
out but it's gonna be coming out
sometime soon
and I kind of took a poll asking people
if they want like a gauntlet or like a
shield or Iron Man helmet or they want a
console
what's up Nicole and it was like 50 50
50 percent wanted like a console and
fifty percent one of the Marvel Legends
item so I might go back to just doing
like the gauntlets and stuff like that
thanks to accent have a great day so
yeah shield yeah a lot of people have
been saying
yeah so not sure but this will probably
be the last giveaway for an xbox one or
a ps4 so I'm sure all of you are
subscribed to my channel if you're not
subscribe to enter and again in the
comments let me know what you all think
you want to see as far as content
concern so thank you awesome caleb best
gotcha wolf wolf of course you knew it
was coming I guess I should explain that
to you so for those of you don't know
when I first started my channel I did a
video on the White Wolf and I can't say
wolf apparently it comes out wolf so a
lot of people made fun of me and the
next video I did are like two videos
later
I said Wolf Wolf just as Elijah Dixon
there you go
sorry so I couldn't say well I couldn't
say wolf but I said wolf wolf as a joke
and everybody loved it
and kind of made fun of me in like a
really really good way so I just kept
saying it so I say well fluff for like
the people have been with me since like
a thousand subscribers so it's kind of
like a tribute to them kind of like an
ode to them just kind of saying hey I
remember who was first here right I
remember who was first here when I first
started when I had a thousand subscriber
so what's up superhero buzz and that's
what I do it for you guys make it really
awesome because I love doing these
videos I love Marvel I love Star Wars
love DC - but I love Marvel like more
than anything I grew up on this stuff
and yeah
Avengers vs. x-men that's for sure come
in so but I love doing this stuff you
guys make it possible for me to do this
as a career which is kind of insane it
is really really insane so yeah thank
you all so I'm just gonna log out now
appreciate you all joining my first live
chat love you all woof-woof